las urnas abrieron en alemania marcando
el principio del fin de la era de angela
merkel tras 16 años en el poder quién
será el nuevo rostro de la república
federal de alemania más de 60 millones
de ciudadanos con derecho a voto fueron
convocados este domingo para contestar
esta pregunta desde las 8 de la mañana
hasta las 6 de la tarde hora local
algunos votantes emitieron su sufragio
por correo incluso la propia merkel
turín ex de una facción nunca ha sido
tan importante votar como este año
fue un poco complicado los candidatos no
no lo pusieron fácil todos teníamos un
poco la impresión de que ninguno de
ellos es realmente apto para el puesto
del próximo canciller a jets
informan hotz que sets el favorito en
las últimas encuestas el candidato
socialdemócrata olaf scholz emitió su
voto en su circunscripción en postdam
cerca de berlín e instó a los votantes a
dar un fuerte resultado a su partido
un buen día el tiempo una buena señal
espero que el mayor número posible de
ciudadanos acuda a agotar deposite su
papeleta y haga posible lo que se
vislumbre en el horizonte en particular
un fuerte resultado para el spd y que
los ciudadanos me encomienden ser el
próximo canciller de alemania por su
parte el candidato de la unión
democratacristiana cannes mier armin
laset cometió un descuido durante la
votación al doblar su papeleta al revés
este error permitió ver su voto algo
prohibido por la ley electoral alemana
sin embargo el presidente de la comisión
electoral aseguró que la papeleta del
líder de la cdu fue considerada válida
baisálov hoy es un día emocionante y
como es una carrera tan reñida cada voto
cuenta hoy no es un día para que hablen
los políticos sino para los votantes
finalmente como es la tradición en el
sur del país ciertos votantes acudieron
a las urnas luciendo sus trajes típicos
regionales